avec anthony saint léger vous avez plus
éternuer c'est bon alors ça va
encore s en vacances et que les
funérailles beaucoup moins drôle anthony
les funérailles de la journaliste
palestinienne
américano-palestiniennes sherin aboa clé
c'était sous vendredi à jérusalem depuis
qu'elle a été tué par balles mercredi à
un faux compte twitter fait beaucoup
parler effectivement et pour cause un
second qu'il se présente comme celui du
frère de la journaliste regarder son nom
mohamed abbou à quai à claix et ac pour
le pseudonyme twitter localiser vous le
voyez au qatar plus de 35 mille abonnés
et il se présente dans sa biographie
comme un journaliste musulman et on le
voit aussi ici qu'il a choisi bien
évidemment la photo de de la journaliste
en question comme image de profil son
premier tweet le voici il date du 11 mai
la mort le jour de la mort de la
journaliste il nous dit ma soeur shirin
a été tué par des balles israéliennes
entre autres j'appelle la communauté
internationale à punir israël dès que
possible et depuis il a enchaîné les
tweets vous avez par exemple celui ci où
il nous dit que vladimir poutine le
président russe l'aurait appelée il y a
sept autres ensuite où il nous dit que
là c'est le pape qui lui aurait
téléphoné pour que la situation s'apaise
et il ya enfin celui ci par exemple où
il affirme qu'à la maison familiale à
jérusalem est est encerclée par l'armée
israélienne voyez des informations qui
sèment le doute donc quant à la
crédibilité de ce compte effectivement
assez d éléments qui doivent mettre la
puce à l'oreille d'ailleurs d'en face à
ce type de situation le média jordanien
de vérification missbach s'est penché
sur ce compte il a repéré plusieurs
détails factuels qui prouve que ce conte
n'a pas l'identité qu'il prétend avoir
première manche irina bois qu'elle n'a
qu'un frère il s'appelle pas mohamed
mais tariq antoun à claix il ad'ailleurs
interview accordé une interview au
gouvernorat de jérusalem c'est la page
facebook que l'on voit derrière moi il
annonçait d'ailleurs la date des
obsèques de sa soeur vous l'avez rappelé
aujourd'hui ensuite dans l'un de ces
tweets
le conte évoque le nom de joseph meir
comme le directeur de l' agence de
renseignement israélienne qui l'aurait
contacté pour qu'il intervienne sur al
jazeera sauf que le chef de service de
sécurité intérieure israélien s'appelle
ron bard et que le directeur du mossad
s'appelle david barnéa et pour vérifier
l'authenticité de ce conte les
observateurs de france 24 ans anthony
ont poussé un peu plus loin au quai
effectivement les traces numériques du
compte ont été passés au peigne fin en
l'occurrence par notre confrère
alexandre cac prend les traces
numériques qu'est ce que c'est ce sont
les informations disponibles
publiquement qui vous permettent de
vérifier l'activité d'un compte mais
dans le passé deux possibilités la
première c'est de vérifier les
interactions avant le 11 mai donc le
jour de la mort de la journaliste on
retrouve par exemple ce tweet du 9 mai
et vous noterez que c'est une réponse
mais que le tweet qui a lancé elle la
discussion est bien a disparu sauf que
sur internet tout ne disparaît pas
totalement grâce au site web archives
que vous avez ici et bien et qui permet
d'archiver donc gratuitement des pages
web vous pouvez retrouver à quoi ça
ressemblait le 9 mai dernier vous le
voyez si vous rentrez dans le moteur de
recherche l'adresse du tweet en question
vous retrouvez à rapidement la date le 9
mai vous cliquez dessus et vous obtenez
cette capture d'écran qui vous donne
donc le tweet original mais notez bien
ici ça n'a absolument rien à voir avec
mohamed abbou cas puisque quart d'heure
score au heat et underscore ce n'est pas
vous l'aurez noté la même orthographe
pourquoi parce que ce compte qui se
présentait d'ailleurs comme un
conseiller technique du koweït qui
twittait régulièrement sur l'actualité
du koweit et bien n'existe plus depuis
le 11 mai la date du décès de la
journaliste et qui a changé non donc
pour devenir mohamed abbou cas il s'est
donc fait passer pour le frère de la
journaliste et depuis d'ailleurs tous
les tweets antérieures 11 mai ont tout
simplement été supprimé alors là anthony
vous venez de nous présenter la première
méthode de déconstruction de ces faux
tweets qu'il y en a une deuxième
effectivement elle vient apporter a plus
de certitudes en fait sur ce sur ce faux
compte c'est de se pencher sur
l'identité numérique du compte twitter
le twitter heidi traduction le numéro de
série finalement compte twitter lorsque
vous créez un compte twitter vous
obtenez un rang et c'est celui ci que
vous obtenez quand vous tapez par
exemple ceux comptant mohamed abbou à 4
dans twitter et dit dans ce suite à
gratter dans ce site gratuit vous
obtenez ce numéro je peux pas vous le
dire évidemment il ya trop de chiffres
mais ça vous donne le rang de création
des comptes cette identité numérique que
l'on retrouve ici vous revenez sur web
archives dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure si vous rentrez rentrez ici le
compte que l'on a vu tout à l'heure et
que vous faire fouiller un petit peu
bien vous obtenez exactement le même
nombre le même twitter heidi cqfd c'est
bien le même conte qui a changé de nom
et d'ailleurs il a fait quatre fois
depuis février tantôt pour twitté sur
l'actualité ukrainienne palestinienne ou
cowboys tienne je le disais alors quels
objectifs a changé aussi souvent
d'identité ce que c'est pour jeter de
l'huile sur le feu est ce que c'est pour
rebondir sur l'actualité pour gagner des
abonnés qui sait vendre des comptes
parce que oui c'est possible vous pouvez
vendre des comptes twitter est bien
impossible à dire toujours est il que
depuis le 11 mai depuis deux jours il a
gagné 5000 abonnés ce n'est pas rien
alors un conte mystère que les
observateurs ont évidemment en contact
et pas de réponse mais elle est la
bienvenue elle me voilà démasqué en tous
les cas merci beaucoup anthony en
revanche votre compte celui de terminale
great and sont authentiques vous allez
retrouver leurs chroniques respectives
sur leur compte suivez les évidemment
merci à vous marquent une très courte
pause retrouve dans quelques minutes
restez avec nous
[Musique]